في غضون ذلك ، يفتح المخترع في صالون الحلاقة و
الضرب الذيل قليلا
معك اتصل لأخذ هاتفي
أنت تتحدث يا رجل يعجبني أن تنهي الأمر شرطة
حيث غادرنا المنزل عندما غادرنا
أعتقد أنني أنتظر خالي من الهم
التقطت الهاتف ، الهاتف هو هاتف دمي
لذلك اتصلت لإرسال تلك الحقيبة مع ابني.
ثم قال الهاتف أنني لا أستطيع العثور عليه
فتح أصدقاء الشرطة بالرد على الهاتف
أصدقاء الشرطة هم أيضا بالمال
قالوا إنك هنا معًا
اخي عصمت انت حسيني بارك الله فيك
احصل عليه منك بالطبع إنه مجاني
لن يترك هذا السلوك المثالي للعالم.
فليسمع ويرى ، ها هو الإنسان
مثلا ، وضعنا الله في نفس الدلو
آمل أن تنفق الكثير من المال بنفس القلب
رؤية الكثير من الأسماك لدرجة أنها ليست أسماكنا
قد يكون قادرًا على فهمها وامتلاكها
بارك الله فينا جميعا
اشترك